قال وزير خارجيه جيبوتي محمود علي يوسف ان
بلاده لم تدن هجمات الحوثيين في البحر
الاحمر لانها تعتبرها اغاثه للفلسطينيين
وفي كلمته بمنتدى المثقفين الصوماليين قال
يوسف ان جيبوتي دوله عربيه واسلاميه وتريد
ان تساعد الفلسطينيين وليس بوسعها
المساعده الا بالمواقف ولذلك لا يمكنها ان
تمنع مساعده
الاخرين
الحوثيون يغيثون اخواننا في فلسطين
وجيبوتي دوله عربيه مسلمه تريد ان تساعد
اشقائها الفلسطينيين وليس بوسعنا مساعدتهم
الا بالمواقف فاذا جاء احد وساعد اخاك
المتضرر فكيف يمكنك ان تمنعه عندما اطلق
الحوثيون اول صاروخ على السفن لم تدن
جيبوتي هذه العمليات لاننا نعتبرها اغاثه
حق لاخواننا في فلسطين
واضاف وزير خارجيه جيبوتي ان بلاده تحفظت
على المشاركه في القوه المتعدده الجنسيات
التي شكلتها واشنطن واشار الى ان توقف
التجاره البحريه في باب المندب سيتسبب في
تضرر اقتصاد جيبوتي ودول
المنطقه ان التوقف التجاره البحريه في باب
المندب سيتسبب بخلل دولي تحفظنا على
المشاركه في مبادره الولايات المتحده
القاضيه بتشكيل تحالف الدول المطله على
البحر الاحمر باب المندب شريان حيوي وعمود
لاقتصاد جيبوتي فاذا توقفت التجاره
البحريه فيه فان اقتصاد جيبوتي ودول
المنطقه سيتضرر ومن الضروري ايجاد حلول
رغم كل ذلك في داخلنا شعور اكبر بان
اخواننا وان عجزوا عن فعل شيء لاغاثه
الفلسطينيين الا ما قام به الحوثيون فاننا
نقول فليبارك الله هذه
الاغاثه